[Musique]
sur cette photo en noir et blanc ils
sont deux frères et un cousin porteur
d'un héritage familial la musique les
racines qui pousseront ces artistes à
colorer ses influences jusqu'à faire
éclore leur propre style musical
éric boone jf gang et christian du cap
digne héritier de la lignée de narmine
ducap et de jean-marc camp nou sami
partageront la scène pour un concert
baptisé trois gars quand on joue on a
connu un second temps que nous serons
terrain on en était là jean-marc ne
s'est hélas depuis tout était là à un
bon open où il était il fait partie de
notre entourage était là et regardez ce
nul est devenu c'est plus ça ne veut
faire passer pour elle ce n'est devenu
et c'est vraiment 3 3
trois styles complémentaires mais
différent même temps c'est ça ne veut
faire passer plus de hurghada s'annonce
on regarde nos bonnes raisons c'est
regarde tout ce que l'on tourne ou héros
garde aujourd'hui que ça donne eric pour
nous c'est christian du cap nous parle
de la scène de leur album en préparation
le public profitera en avant première de
ses créations originales et de la fusion
de ces trois styles musicaux question
les gasy francs à l'époque a été folle
comme un mail et un peu l'ardeur au
cubain down saccani fait son affaire il
fait ça canif et son musée sur le sort
que les lamas c'est la seconde ti-boutte
titres hybrides sai y compas sa voix
presque 7 l'est pour autant c'est
culturellement nous les ans ensemble
le plus vieux de construire c'est ça
notre avis ou de culture et notre
culture l effet nous la vivons vous et
ça va donner à massat du fou at il faut
peut-être pas assez coude est peut-être
non plus ce coup ci atteint lequel pas
moi comment sa tige au rsa mais à nous
tous car nous sommes hélas tu ressens
nour sans nourriture sans cause et
partager leur culture leur attachement à
la musique créole pour ce trio
d'artistes le rendez vous est pris ce
sera le 31 août à 20h au théâtre plein
air de saint-gilles
[Musique]